hey hi praque good afternoon thanks for
joining yeah good afternoon yeah thank
you for giving me this
opportunity yeah so maybe we can get
started with a quick round of
introduction uh then maybe we can deep
dive further in the
questions
sure so I'll start with the intro first
um so I started my journey as a cloud
engineer uh I think 5 and a half years
back uh so um in that process I started
with development and uh I it for like
couple of months and then I slowly moved
to the deployment part of it uh and I
started liking creating infrastructures
automating them uh creating cicd
pipelines and um automating things in
Python shell and whatever way it is
possible because uh making things easier
was one of uh the thing that I um loving
about it and U then I uh moved to a
different organization where where I
worked as a Solutions engineer uh so
understanding customer problems um like
suggesting them a good architectural
overview and how they can make uh or use
the product in a better way uh and after
that I uh moved to a different
organization where I worked as a senior
devops engineer uh and my entire
responsibility was uh to like automate
the things and make processes easier uh
how we can roll out the uh updates uh
frequently without any uh Interruption
and making sure the reliability and
highly High availability um as well uh
so um after that um in my current
organization I'm working um as a
consultant um and I've worked with
different engagements um across um teams
um and um yeah so it's mostly about the
devops best practices and automating
things yeah so thank you prik for your
brief introduction so uh to start with
uh consider that you want to develop a
uh e-commerce
application uh that will be accessible
throughout the world okay so it is a
international application uh the
requirement is it should be uh highly
scalable robust and it should be highly
available okay so you are free to use uh
all the AWS Services which you like uh
yeah so the the requirement is simple it
should be highly scalable it should be
reliable and it should be highly
available yeah okay sure uh so I'll
start with um the networking part of it
uh so we will be uh using a VPC uh and a
sub subnet so I think there should be at
least subnets uh so two for Fab Layer
Two for app layer and two for database
layer if uh uh if the database is like
um resides in uh in a VPC like RDS or
document DV uh and um uh in those
private subnets we will be having our
application uh servers uh in the app
subnets and then in database subnets we
will be having our databases like RDS it
could be MySQL it could be Aurora or
postgress um or it could be document DB
cluster as well and uh we will also be
having uh like net Gateway as well as
internet gateway for our PPC and then we
will be having uh Transit Gateway as
well if you want if you want to access
uh data from our data center which
resides in the organization or somewhere
else as a local and then uh we will be
using um load balancers for equally
Distributing the traffic across our um
uh uh across our different different uh
instances um we will also be
implementing Autos scaling to make sure
we can hover the load um uh and increase
uh the number of servers um whenever um
there is a high traffic coming in we
will be utilizing um a RDS for
structural databases uh which supports
Oracle post SQL my SQL mssql Etc and we
will also be using Dynamo DB if we want
to use no SQL database um we can also
utilize document uh and so networking uh
we have good uh database we got for
storage we will be using S3 um so for
storing um uh any object uh white data
we can use S3 and we can also use S3 for
um hosting our static content um and
over that we will be utilizing
cloudfront uh to as a CDN to deliver
that content uh faster uh with a l
latency for uh DNS management to 53 is
there uh and um for uh so network is
done storage is done database is done um
and um I think compute yeah for uh for
uh compute we can utilize the e clusters
uh to host the back end uh and ECS as
well it it based it is based on how we
are architecting our application and if
it is monolith we can also um go with uh
the ec2 instances uh and a Stam is one
of the thing that we can go if we are
using S so I think this is a very high
level architecture that uh uh that we
can create for an e-commerce
application okay okay perfect so you
mentioned monolith and microservices in
your answer right so you mention eks ECS
and normal ec2 instance based MTH so
under what circumstances or under what
requirements you will choose either
monolith or microservices and which is
more beneficial against each
other yeah uh so uh uh it depends if we
are just starting with our uh product uh
and we don't have the expertise uh or or
the affordability I'll say um to have so
much of resources that will learn
kubernetes that uh manage those clusters
because e you have to manage the
Clusters you have to manage the E
versions uh you have to learn how to
implement all those things and it could
be a bit difficult but like if you have
a uh if you if you're having a startup
and if you just want to get started
without um all those hurdles then you
can just start with a monolith
application and also if your
architecture does not require to be that
complex then it's better to go with
monolith but if you want flexibility and
much configuration management and all
then it it's better to go with the
container based system like eks or
ECS okay so what is more complicated
according to you is it kubernetes based
systems or maybe monolith so if you have
a large teams say let's say 10 or 12
developers and devops Engineers working
on your product so which one will you
choose will you choose monolith or
microservices or maybe
eks yeah uh so uh it will majorly again
depend um on U on the architecture of
the application so let's say if it is
having like 70 to 80 Services uh so I
need to manage like routes for all those
um and um also like the back end of all
those applications so it's easier for me
as a devops to uh manage all this uh via
um via a cuberes based systems because I
don't want to manage all those routes in
a mon system where I have to create the
routes for all those so let's say if I
use engin and to create all those routes
for enginex then it will pass to an ALB
and then eventually an ec2 or something
uh but if it is eks I can have a service
created for this we can we can easily
automate it though it is manageable in
monolith as well but like having a
kubernetes based architecture make sure
that our application um is reli reliably
running because whenever it goes up like
eks uh will automatically keep it
running uh it will alert us like
monolith also does that but eeks uh
makes makes it uh easier for us because
it is
managed oh okay
okay um yeah so and in case of
monitoring or maybe observability uh how
would you monitor this entire ecosystem
or maybe entire application so what kind
of services will you use will you use
all the aw services or maybe some
external help as
well yeah so when it comes to monitoring
uh we have um very good tools available
out sort of AWS so I'll go with data do
um and grafana uh for the uh visibility
uh because Z do also provides all the
infr level um loggings like what request
we are uh getting and uh what is the
latency time um and um if there is any
error if there is any warning so all the
traces related to the application in uh
uh AWS x-ray is one of the services
within AWS that I'll go with for
application Level insights if there is
any application bottleneck with an API
or something uh if you want a very
simpler architecture then um then it is
AWS Cloud work because it also has a lot
of log insights within it uh so every
service has a log stream created if we
going to get it
correctly okay so if cloudwatch and
x-ray has all the required features then
why exactly you would require data dog
in the first
place yeah so uh it totally depends on
our requirement um Cloud wise does
provide a lot of features but when it
comes to um configuration so let's say
if I want these much applications in a
group uh this much projects in a group
if I want to make sure that these much
parameters or matrices outside of the
supportability of cloud watch then I can
go for those custom matrics um with the
open source tool rather than AWS manage
because uh there are certain limitation
when it's when it comes to configuring
cloudwatch so we we can't uh like go out
of those um limitations so for that
purpose we can use um some open source
tools as
well okay okay so uh in case of a
disaster okay so just in case as I
mentioned in the beginning so it is a
multi- region kind of or a maybe
international application just in case
any region goes down or maybe any
availability go availability Zone goes
down in your uh system so how would you
react or how would you build systems or
maybe how would you automate stuff so
that your application is not impacted at
all yeah so um for Disaster Recovery
purposes uh we have to make sure that um
our core um database whereever data is
residing um is replicated not just um
across a but across region as well so
although we will be having multi a
configuration for our production
deployment we need to make sure that we
are having a copy of it uh uh across
region as well so we we can so we need
to configure the cross region U uh
replica of the RDS snapshots um um which
is which should be synchronous of course
so we don't lose any data um uh and for
like storage whatever storage that we
have in our aset we need to set up a
cross region application for that S3
bucket as well and if require we can
also um use like um a global load
balancer uh which will make sure that if
a region goes down and it is not serving
then we can utilize the data dat is
available uh within the next available
region and U for Dynamo DB a global
table is a
um that we can use uh make use of for
those kind of uh disasters so yeah these
are some of the um high level things
that uh I I'll Implement whenever
designing an
architecture okay so we spoke about
observability we spoke about uh fall
tolerance and Dr so if we want to secure
this particular application okay if you
want to secure this application as well
as the cloud infrastructure so what best
practices or what measures you will take
so that your application becomes
secure yeah uh so when it comes to
security of the application um so first
thing as an e-commerce application um
that the threat it gets is like DS
attack uh so we need to implement a AWS
Shield um which which is a manage AWS
service which will make sure that
whenever there is a traffic that is not
expected and it is not legal traffic
I'll say uh so it blocks it uh to a
certain uh level so it does not impact
the running application uh and we can
also Implement AWS we uh which is like
web application firewall which makes
sure uh that our application uh level
applic application related threads U are
like managed properly uh and whenever
there is a compromise to the security uh
so uh we'll make sure that uh we are uh
securing that application uh using rules
in that uh V and uh when it comes to
like accessing uh Services uh within AWS
then in that case we can uh use IM roles
for the Le privileged accesses so like
if uh eks wants to access Dynam Aus uh
it is only utilizing the r need to and
not more than
that okay great uh so yeah so moving on
to the cost optimization section so the
customer is quite cost sensitive okay
and um as we are using lot of AWS
Services right so AWS is not cheap right
it is going to incur a lot of costs
right so with respect to your
observability security and Dr so uh what
cost optimization measures you will take
uh so that it does not affect the
customer in Tak in in terms of taking a
decision whether to choose this
particular service or not so basically
any five key points that you will
Implement in your systems so that uh we
are also kind of uh making sure there
are no uh humongous
costs okay uh so cost optimization as an
like entire application or uh only
within um the storage part uh it can be
it can be generic to aw so it can be
within all the services it can be with
ec2 instances it can be with S3 buckets
it can be with RDS instances anything
that comes to your mind uh it is okay
for me sure uh so start with uh the
compute part uh so when it comes to like
having the instances so we need to make
sure what our application actually
requires whether it will be Memory
intensive like computer in uh intensive
or like GPU intensive uh based on that
we need to select the right uh instance
typ for that uh and uh we also need to
make sure that we are having a reserved
instances plans as well uh because we
are if we are sure that we will be using
these many instances for these many
months or years then it better to go
with the reserves instances policies
which gives us um discount up to like 70
to 80% and saves us a lot of money uh
and we can also use the uh spot
instances which which are cheaper uh
even though uh we uh we are not sure
when those uh instances can be taken U
Back but it is better to go with the
sport instances for any uh nonpr uh use
cases and for stateless application
where where we don't uh really need the
reliability for the instances to run
continuously uh and for storage uh like
within S3 we can have the right S3
storage classes so for frequently access
data we can go with the3 standard one
and for infrequent one we can have the
um AI IA configured and then for um like
the archives and uh as well we don't
want the storage to be standard but we
can use the acid gler um and uh when it
comes to like file system uh storage uh
like EBS uh then we we need to make sure
that we are selecting the right um EBS
types so there are like gp2 gp3 io1 all
those available but we need to make sure
that we are selecting uh which which uh
like serves the purpose um of that
particular um like EBS type and we
should not be using like uh iops based
High highly iops based EBS volume if it
is not
required and um so yeah and when it
comes to like data transfer cost within
AWS we need to um uh make sure we are
using um like PPC endpoints for private
connectivity uh to avoid uh data data
transfer charges because like n Gateway
costs a lot so and uh so we need to make
sure when we are transferring the data
within availability zones or within the
regions uh then these costs are are
taken care of and uh for yeah for um RDS
we can use um the RDS res instances same
as the ec2s and uh for like for cicd and
all like when we use like code build or
code pipeline so uh we can also optimize
those builds uh um or tweak those
configurations uh to build it faster uh
like having like stage build um and like
using an Alpine image or something so
these are the uh like some of the things
that I'll look look into so one final
question on this particular use case so
since this is a big Enterprise right it
is an Enterprise like Amazon or flip
cart so uh they have certain on premises
systems as well okay so they want access
to the e-commerce applications servers
databases from their on-prem systems so
what kind of services or what what kind
of uh systems would you use so that you
have established the connectivity
between your on premises and your
e-commerce application that is residing
in
AWS uh so there are several ways to uh
achieve that um one thing is we can have
a s side to side VPN connectivity uh
within AWS so there will be a customer
gate and then there will be an AWS
Gateway uh which can have the
connectivity um so it will be over the
Internet um of course uh but it will be
a private connectivity one not we are
not like directly targeting U the E
instance to connect to it uh and uh one
more uh thing that we can do is like use
uh make use of direct connect uh which
is like uh physical uh lines or uh
physical cables um which which connects
your data center to AWS data center or
availability Zone so that that is very
much faster and safer but but it costs a
lot but if we have a lot of data to be
transferred um from your data center uh
to the availability zones or if you have
a lot of data to manage uh on the flow
then it's better to have a direct
connect uh uh connection between them
because in longer term it will save us
the
cost okay uh yeah so prati uh that was
it for the AWS thing so moving on to
kubernetes and eks what exactly is the
stateful set and how it is different
from a
deployment yeah uh so stateful uh set is
something uh that is like uh so let's
say if uh I'm having so many parts uh
for a service so uh in stateful sets uh
it will make sure that there is a
dependency between the parts so U even
the provisioning of the parts will be
sequential uh it won't be like all parts
are coming up together and then like
shutting down together so there is a
sequence that it follows even for the
rule backs and updates as well uh to uh
to make uh the scaling uh like
efficiently but uh uh in case of a
deployment like all the um pods um are
stateless so there is no dependency
between them uh and uh let's say uh if
and they don't have a unique identity to
be uh uh to be clear and they are
treated the same way if one is replaced
the new part will uh not be able to like
distinguish U which one was down uh but
in in case of Street full set u the the
Pod have a unique identity uh and
they're assigned uh an ordinal index as
well uh so even that identity that
identity persist even if the Pod is
rescheduled so uh this is important for
application that needs to like maintain
uh State across part restarts uh when it
comes to storage uh so uh deployment
typically has stateless storage uh so it
means like data is not preserved uh when
the Pod is deleted uh so if persistent
storage is needed uh think it has to be
manually managed or associated with a
pod uh U so it doesn't require unique
persistent uh per part uh but in State
uh stateful set like each board uh can
be associated with a unique persistent
volume uh this ensure that the P data
has preserved um across restarts um or
rescheduling like which which makes it
ideal for stateful applications where
data persistent is crucial okay any any
example that comes to your mind where
you have utilized stateful applications
or maybe uh stateful
sets yeah um so uh let's say if I have
to manage a database or if I have to
have a database in um uh in a cluster so
for that purpose it's better to go with
the state full set uh because uh it is
persistent uh it has a volume it won't
be like killed uh and my data will be
gone um but um if I have if I want to
have a stateless application which is
just like getting a request and then
delivering it uh delivering the data
after fetching it from database then if
that service even if it restarts it will
not uh lose any data it will not lose uh
any uh state or something so in that
particular case I'll go with the
deployment uh for a service which is
serving data from here to there and for
database kind of a thing I'll go with
stateful
sell sure praque so how do you create a
multi-stage Docker
build yeah uh so uh multistage build in
Docker uh like allow us to use uh
multiple from statements uh in a single
Docker file basically uh so uh each has
a separate build stage uh and uh this is
this becomes very useful when we have to
create smaller um and more efficient
images by allow allowing us to like copy
only the necessary artifacts from one
stage uh and uh it it will remove
everything else which is like not
required so uh the major things uh uh of
this uh functionality or technique is uh
each from statement uh like starts a new
build stage uh and we can have as many
stage uh as we want uh like each uh
stage will use a different base image uh
and uh artifact for artifact copying uh
we can just copy the artifact from one
stage to another uh using the copy
statement so we can just write like copy
from this stage and then uh whatever
stage we want to copy to and uh this
approach is uh especially uh useful uh
to build like complex uh uh to have
complex build process where the build uh
environment is different from the
runtime environment so let's say um I'll
have an example of a multi-stage build
uh where uh we are building the
application uh for gang so we can write
like from gulang uh some version and
then we will be setting up the working
directory and then we'll be copying uh
the um module manifest uh from with the
copy command so copy go something and U
uh go something and then slash um uh and
we will also download the Go module and
now we want to uh like build the uh
application uh so what we will be doing
is like a run a uh go build command it
will build the application and now we
create a minimal runtime image so how we
can create that is we can just set the
work uh we can just use a from statement
and use an Alpine image and set the
working directory with a uh workd
command and then we can copy the uh
previously created build uh from the
previous stage to uh this particular
stage and then we can just run the
commands so um how what are the benefits
of this is like multistage builds um uh
helps us to create optimized uh Docker
images by making sure it separate outs
uh the build environment from the rtime
environment and it minimizes the final
image size uh and this becomes useful uh
for production environment where a
smaller image size are preferred for
faster deployment than like um a reduce
attack
surface all right uh so as we know that
kubernetes is quite complex right so it
is not easy and uh it is not for
beginners certainly so uh what kind of
troubleshooting scenarios you have faced
in your current project or maybe in
production systems that you would like
to highlight to me so there are several
uh errors that we Face uh while
maintaining our clusters um so one
common error is uh crash loop back off
error uh where the p uh Port goes in um
the pending State uh due to some issues
so it could be due to like uh it is not
able to fetch the image or it is not
able to start the application so we can
uh run the get events command and get
the events of that part and we can also
describe part if there is any
misconfiguration uh that needs to be
taken care of but the gut events give us
a good idea of what is happening and
what what has caused the failure um
another uh issue could be uh you're not
able to like fetch the secrets due to
some permission issues uh so we need to
sort it out as well uh so uh one more
major issue that we face is uh n is not
having the enough resources um to uh to
I'll say scale the part so we have to
like add on the nodes as well so uh even
though it is aut scalable sometimes uh
there are chances that it is not able to
scale uh beyond the Max Capacity that we
set so in that uh in those cases we need
to like manually um like increase the
note count so yeah these are some of the
issues that we face all right all right
so in microservices World there would be
n number of PODS right so there would be
thousands of PODS okay and uh it is not
possible to a human to log into each and
every pod and get logs out of any
particular pod so what kind of loging uh
mechanism you have implemented in your
eeks cluster or in your kubernetes
cluster so that the log files or the
logs are centrally accessible to each
and every developer or devops engineer
so have you worked on a centralized
logging kind of a
solution sure um so to answer that uh we
have implemented uh data do uh agent uh
for all the uh services so uh it it acts
as a demon set in uh every node um so it
is since it is a demon set it runs in
all the nodes and get data for all the
services and we can see which services
are having errors if there are any
warnings or info uh in the data do
console only uh so when we go to U uh
the application insights we see uh all
the data related to how the application
is performing if there are any errors
that is coming in uh so yeah to answer
your question we are using for that and
to see uh the logs uh for our local
let's say if you don't want to go to
data do and uh to like manage uh our
cluster so we are using lens for
that all right all right so I see a lot
of gitops uh and Argus CD in your CV so
what exactly is gitops and argu cidd and
how it is different from traditional
cicd pipelines or traditional deop
setup yeah so giops is um is a very uh
well known thing uh now in devops world
uh in this our source of Truth relies uh
in the kit repository so whenever we
push or more changes to good reposer it
acts as a source of Truth so whatever
changes that we have mer we'll get uh
build it like tested and whatever uh
steps that we want to do and then
further it will be ready for the
deployment um so for um um like the
deployment we used Argo CD which was
responsible for U deployments within a
kubernetes cluster so whether it be a
service and deployment stateful sets
Secrets configs everything was managed
by AR CD and it was very easier for us
to like um have a good flow of how our
application is updating what services
Parts uh what kind of update strategy is
there what kind of ruling back strategy
there so orus city was easier for us to
manage so the pipeline uh was in gav
actions uh where we build it tested and
uh done the steps and Aro city was uh
something that we finally deployed uh
those artifacts to and then it was then
deployed by to
ekser okay so you mentioned about
deployment strategies like so uh what
kind of deployment strategies are there
in kubernetes or or how many types maybe
you can
Implement uh so uh there are several uh
deployment strategies uh the very uh
famous one uh is like Blu green
deployment uh where we have entire Set
uh of application ready to be served uh
side by side uh and uh we try and test
that particular say so we can say like
if we are having V1 uh and um we want
the V2 to be deployed then we make the
entire infa ready uh for the uh for
service and then we test it if that
works well we shift the traffic from V1
to uh V2 and another one is uh ruling
update uh where we uh Define uh the
strategy uh for the ports to update
incrementally so it will uh replace old
ports uh with the new ones um uh few at
a time so it will not be like all the
parts are going down and then all the
new parts are coming up so it will um
like like try to shut the old pods down
one by one and uh like make the new one
uh coming uh application has multiple
version running simultaneously uh and
this is good for like production use
cases where up time is crucial and it
has allows for gradual replacement uh
which can be monitored for issues so
let's say uh my old version was running
seamlessly and new version is having
some issues and I'll get the errors I
can see those and I can stop that and
roll roll it back instead of like having
U all the parts updating at the same
time and then getting
surprises and so I mentioned blue green
I me mention rolling and one is like
Canary deployment as well uh so um in
Canary deployment it releases the new
version to a very small subset of users
first so let's say 5 or 10% of traffic
which allows the testing in production
um before gradually rolling it out for
the entire user B uh how it helps is um
it uh minimizes the downtime to nearly
zero uh because uh the traffic is split
between the old and the new version so
it it it is ideal for testing new
feature in production with a very
minimal risk uh and if the cry version
works well as expected then it can be
gradually rolled out to the entire user
base okay okay yeah yeah great uh so
consider that you have deployed an
application in eks okay so this
application requires access to dynamodb
tables and your S3 buckets okay so uh to
give you a scenario so your pods will
require access to your S3 objects and uh
they will also require uh access to the
Dynam DB tables okay and uh I should not
configure any access key and secret key
within the application so that is one
use case or maybe one requirement so how
will you ensure that this requirement is
fulfilled sure uh so for that purpose uh
we can create an IM R uh for service
account uh which is called as AA and uh
to securely ground like eks sports
access to a services like you mentioned
as Theo Dynamo DB uh we can make use of
IM roles uh uh which we can assign uh so
we can assign a permission uh to
kubernetes Services uh accounts which
which can be ultimately utilized by the
ports so we can have an IM policy
created where we will be mentioning the
S3 buckets Dynam tables and what kind of
access you want like put table put item
or like get bucket put uh put item uh
get bucket get items and all and once we
create the IM Rule and policy we need to
um create a service service account in
kubernetes uh and uh within the service
account we can mention the IM rule uh
that we are about to assume and we can
also mention the rule um role in all and
uh then after that we can just use uh
those services and it will uh in our
part configuration we can mention the
service account then it will which will
be utilized to access those services and
we are good to all right all right uh so
if you have to develop an application
and deploy that application across your
kubernetes clusters so what would you
prefer uh would you prefer deploying
using a Helm chart or maybe a
traditional kubernetes manifest file so
which is easier and what would you
choose yeah uh so it depends if our
application um is very uh big and have a
lot of services deployments and and
config Maps then it's better to go with
uh H charts because these are the
templates uh within the kubernetes
Manifest so uh it instead of like
managing multi yl files manually we can
make use of Helm charts uh that package
together all the necessary resources and
Helm chart also simplify the maintenance
by allowing uh us to use variables and
templating so we can Define all the
values in values. yaml and use it across
our manifest and uh which becomes useful
while managing multiple environments we
can just change the values and we are
good with it uh and when it comes to
like traditional manifest um so whenever
the number of resources go uh uh grows
so we need to uh make sure to manage
those files U uh properly because like
we have the repetitive configuration uh
which can change across environment so
uh it involves a lot of uh writing and
maintaining separate hamls uh uh for
each kuet uh kubernetes
resource right right so the kubernetes
part or E part is done so let's move to
terraform so consider a multiac account
structure in AWS or maybe an
organization or Landing Zone kind of a
setup where we have multiple accounts so
we have log archive account we have
Security account we have networking
account and then we have uh application
accounts like your production U Dev okay
so considering these many accounts the
accounts are already created uh using
terraform and we have to create
infrastructure uh in all these accounts
and we have to deploy application
applications in all these accounts so
what would be your ideal terraform
directory structure to manage this
entire ecosystem or to manage this
entire Landing
Zone sure uh so when it comes to the
directory structure uh so uh it will
depend on two things one is the kind of
resources I'm having so as you mentioned
we are having uh separate network
security um and logging account uh uh
and the application accounts as well
like account a account B account C and
along with uh multiple environment so um
my structure would look like uh so uh I
will be having modules created uh for
all those logging security and
networking resources which I will be
reusing within the different uh
environment um so how my structure would
look like is I will be having um uh a TF
modules directory which is uh root
directory in that I will be having
multiple modules so for networking I'll
be having module for logging uh for
archiving uh and for other purposes if I
want to have any other account so let's
say for serving or something and then uh
I'll have environment based different
accounts so uh environment a or let's
say environment da environment U
environment prod and in those uh uh
directories of environments I'll be
having uh the configuration for that
specific environment so I can reuse
those modules by just passing on the
variables and uh uh by reusing the
modules uh I mean we will be utilizing
the TF modules directory modules and we
can just pass on the variables to that
particular particular module and um and
provision the inra so same will be for
uh uat and prod as well so we we don't
need to uh like write the same
repetitive code of all those resources
again and again we can just reuse it in
modules okay so uh you mentioned modules
right so modules are also the custom
modules which you develop and there are
few modules which are official modules
from AWS on the terraform site right so
uh if you create your custom modules so
what benefit it gives because the some
of the modules or most of the modules
are already developed by Third parties
and it is certified by AWS and terraform
so why would you create your own
modules yeah uh so it depends on a
requirement if we want to have only uh
certain parameters to be used uh then we
can have only those many parameters as
inputs uh or I'll say variables uh which
will be passed on because it won't
support the uh all the set of variable
that is provided by AWS terraform module
which is like official one so if I want
to have any uh manual configuration
change for that particular module then I
can use write my own module even though
it will have the same uh resource block
behind the scene and same variables um
and same parameters behind the scenes
but uh it involves uh rewriting uh the
module by yourself even though you can
um also use the manage AWS one and write
a wrapper on top of that and reuse that
so have you ever worked on Dynamic
blocks in terraform and if yes what
exactly is that and what is the use case
of that so I recently used a dynamic
block while creating a Dynam table where
I required multiple attributes to be
used uh so for that um I passed um map
uh including a lot of attributes uh and
which for every map uh value uh it
creates uh a new configuration block uh
and uh it will just iterate over that
for Loop uh uh I'll not say follow IED
over that mapping and it will just
create all the configuration attributes
which is passed in that
Dynamic all right uh so one last
question uh pratique and then maybe we
can wrap up this interview so how would
you create a perfect or a near perfect
devops pipeline so you are free to use
any any kind of tools it can be open
source it can be Cloud uh I want to know
the answer right from the developer
checks in his code till the actual
production deployment so yeah sure uh so
um when uh whenever a developer um
checks in his go
[Music]
to uh testing phase uh so the testing
tool could be uh sonar Cu uh and um then
there will be a security testing phase
for that application and for that um AB
spider is a good Tool uh which provides
like comprehensive security testing for
web web and web and mobile application
and after after that it will go to um uh
the container security um um Step where
the the uh container will be um scanned
for any vulnerabilities so Aqua security
is one of the tool that uh I have used
and which worked well and uh we can also
um like if uh we are using let's say
infrastructure as code then we can also
use teras scan which is a code scanner
for infrastructure as code and for
Secrets management or within the
application we will be using Secrets
manager or let's say if it is open
source U uh then we can use uh do
Doppler as well uh or like if if you
want to go ahead with the Hashi VA then
it also works well and for cicd Tool we
can use uh genkins or get leci or Circle
C or octopus deployer whichever serves
purpose well but like zenkin is an open
source so if you just want to get
started it's a good tool with a lot of
features uh for runtime security and
monitoring uh cdig is uh one of the best
tool that uh that I've used and like uh
for cloud security Prisma Cloud works
well so these are some of the tools that
I'll go with okay and what would be your
deployment tool so you forgot to mention
the deployment tool so if it is a eks
based application so how would you
deploy your uh Docker image onto the E
cluster yeah uh so uh if it is an e
image I'll go with um the Argo CD uh
which is perfect for the E for
CLS okay okay yeah uh thank you so much
pratique for your time for this
interview um I really appreciate thank
you thank you so much thanks AIT for
your time thank you